alors sur le site officiel de la
Comédie-Française votre biographie ne
mentionne pas Classe Mannequin vous leur
avez pas dit
Laurent la petite bonsoir
alors je devrais dire Laurent Lafitte de
la Comédie-Française
n'est pas obligé vous êtes né
très fier d'accueillir des gens de la
Comédie Française pour tout à l'heure là
pour Michel Leeb en fait le problème
c'est pas de ressembler à Michel Leeb
physiquement c'est au niveau de l'humour
ça pourrait poser un problème c'est que
vous avez beaucoup plus d'humour que lui
ça c'est son langage que vous avez eu
très tôt la vocation oui à 15 ans vous
jouez dans un téléfilm suite à une
petite annonce vous avez vu dans
François vous envoyer une lettre avec un
photomaton et tout et puis j'ai passé le
casting et j'étais engagé ensuite une
formation assez classique le Cours
Florent le conservatoire et puis vous
êtes engagé dans le classement
oui professionnel quoi j'ai appris mon
métier à prendre un texte l'interpréter
et en vivre aussi vous êtes quand même
le premier membre de la Comédie
française à avoir commencé dans une
syncope de merde quand même peut-être
ça a été une formidable école pour vous
pour apprendre à jouer la comédie
notamment jouer la comédie avec une
érection j'imagine
ça c'est encore une fois son langage que
vous mais il fait il faut être très
concentré quand on fait une sitcom parce
que ça tombe très vite c'est une bonne
école alors sur le site officiel de la
Comédie Française votre biographie ne
mentionne pas Classe Mannequin vous leur
avez pas dit alors c'est sur mon CV
maintenant sur les bio peut-être non je
sais pas si c'est ça
[Rires]
pourquoi Nicolas Sarkozy trouvait la
Comédie Française chiante parce qu'il
préférait faire ses premières photos
officielles à Disneyland
alors Laurent vous êtes ici ce soir pour
un film intitulé les beaux jours de
Marion Vernoux avec Fanny Ardant et
Patrick Chesnay qui sort le 19 juin
faire le pitch alors Fanny Ardant est
une dentiste fraîchement retraité elle
vit avec Patrick Chesnay qui lui est
dentiste toujours en activité et là pour
combler le vide de la nouvelle vie de
leur mère ses filles lui offrent un
abonnement découverte dans un club pour
seniors qui s'appelle les beaux jours et
là au beau jour il y a un prof
d'informatique qui est vous et la
passion de va naître entre Fanny Ardant
donc comme la soixantaine et vous oui
c'est pas une cougar c'est pas une femme
qui cherche la compagnie de de plus
jeune qu'elle et moi c'est je suis pas
non plus un gars qui cherche forcément
des femmes plus mûres c'est juste deux
disponibilités à ce moment-là qui vont
faire que que ça va être possible ce qui
est formidable avec vous c'est que vous
pouvez passer comme ça de au-delà du
périple ou de qui a retué PAM rose à
Marion Bernou très facilement c'est bien
mais c'est la CHAN j'ai la chance qu'on
me propose des rôles différents aussi
dans l'humour moi je me souviens de
votre spectacle Laurent Lafitte comme
son nom l'indique en 2008 mais c'est
insensé vraiment insensé j'étais allé
vous voir pour le dire et là vous avez
fait un carton donc au César et Antoine
de Caunes a envie de vous passer le
relais l'année prochaine je vais faire
comment pour que ça soit pas trop chiant
les César vous allez passer des extraits
de films américains
je vais pas les présenter surtout non
non c'est lui qui présente les Césars
l'année prochaine il avait dit que
c'était vous non il avait dit que si
jamais que si jamais il ne le faisait
plus il me verrait bien me faire à sa
place mais non non il le fait moi je
suis fan de vous merci et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de Inna larditube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu